little bit of news at just broke I guess
right before we went live black ops 2 3
there's this weird like starter pack
thing they're living on steam now just
want to briefly talk about it so for
those you know no this is a 15 the sorry
1499 $15 multiplayer only slice of black
ops 3 there we go that's to releasing on
steam it's kind of been like something
people have suggested might happen for a
while I was talking to Andy before the
show apparently the call of duty
campaign and multiplayer have been two
separate executables on PC for years and
so you can get this it's only got ranked
multiplayer doesn't have any the zombies
or campaign doesn't have any like custom
games and you have sort of stuff but
1499 it's limited on you can buy it from
either today up until februari 29th so
they're like testing this edge and then
you can upgrade if you want for 45 bucks
call of duty yeah upgrade 45 bucks for
three hundred percent of what you just
for the campaign and something that
makes a lot of sense not we've been
talking about that happening for a while
because it just seems to be where this
is going you have people who exclusively
play multiplayer I mean there's a reason
that call of duty black ops 3 was still
the biggest selling game for January
yeah like it's still something that
sells really well on the power of that
multiplayer experience highest selling
game on this current generation consoles
as well and some people still love that
story experience like I I enjoy playing
through a gaming getting a quick slice
of story and I enjoy that more usually
than a multiplayer thing and being able
to separate those out like this is a
chance for them to test that I like are
people going to be interested in doing
that especially now like after the game
has been out if anyone's been on the
fence and you just want to get in and
play multiplayer with your friends it's
a really low barrier to entry for that
but it's kind of a smart way to do that
too also avoid any criticism of doing
this win the game releases is making
that sound kind of crappy exactly it's
interesting though because it is like a
precedence as well where they've now
decided to do it so now next year
everyone's going to be looking to see if
they do it at lunch which they probably
won't write like that seems like well I
don't know like if this is really
successful I can see this being the
launch strategy no here's here's the way
the word we're gonna deliver this
because there are so many other
multiplayer centric games that are
coming out even at full price like
watch which is y a multiplayer game
there's not a single player story with
that you're gonna get this you're gonna
play multiplayer that's it eight million
people sign up to that beta as well so
super popular I'm sure we're not talking
about Street Fighter no a many people
are trying to get online with that at
the moment and I also had a quick look
is this i believe is only is a pc only
deal i'm pretty sure and I looked at it
on Steam to see where call of duty were
Blops 3 ranked within like the sort of
where's everyone everyone's playing at
the moment standing like 22nd so perhaps
this is a situation where look we've got
the most popular game on consoles at the
moment it's maybe not it's maybe not do
like there's other it's plenty of
first-person show i'm in team fortress 2
it's free to play i know but it's like
number two global Offensive no sorry
team fortress number for global
Offensive number two like even guys
still there number seven so like maybe
that gives them and in that way i guess
if you grow the player base on pc then
chances are more people will buy it the
next year do you play call of duty on pc
no no I know I like to check out the
campaign and I try to jump in a
multiplayer before I realize like yeah I
still don't really love this yes so it's
weird I it for me it always like I'm a I
played all the classic apologies on PC
and I love first-person shooters at pc
some reason blops has always just been a
console game i dive into the campaign
for a while sometimes complete them
taste in multiplayer and then jump off
again I mean part of that might be hurt
by the fact that it does come out every
year we have these other shelters that
are very focused on upgrading the
experience that you have whereas you can
always count on there's going to be a
new call of duty every year and so it's
like madden or any of the sports games
like you they have a dedicated fan base
who know what they're getting into
they're gonna buy this every year and
for a lot of people that's probably the
only game that they buy are one of two
or three games they buy in a year yeah
super popular and one of the questions
here just looking into the chat burgers
Dex is that like him already yeah
wonderful and what's the highest selling
game diss generation it while the
activision i guess the numbers came out
they had their call last week and three
of the four games of this generation hi
selling games are theirs and number one
is Blops three interesting enough i
guess the install base is finally and
yeah interesting i've just like a broke
just before we came on so i said i
mention it so if you have any thoughts
in the if you're watching this live or
watching us on demand let us know what
you think will you be picking this up
for 1499 if I got
weeks to do it let us know